各位朋友,大家好,我是期货琼墨。
上一节课呢,跟大家分享了交易系统的框架内容。
那么这一节课的话,会跟大家分享5分钟短线交易系统的一个主要内容。
那么在我这个5分钟短线交易系统里面的话,我们有三个概念可能需要先理解一下。
那么这三个概念呢,它构成了我这个交易系统的一个核心。
第一个就是均线。那么在我这个交易系统里面,均线是起着主要的一个交易依据。
那么250日均线通常是我们开餐平餐的一个主要依据。
当然有时候后为了需要,会增加120日均线,作为我们这个付助。
第二个是协力。那么协力的话,就是我们这个均线250日均线的一个角度的问题。
那么通常我们用这个协力来判断这个行情的多空。
当角度向上倾斜的时候呢,我们可以看作是多投力量比较强,
所以我们这个时候主要是以作多为主。
那么当角度是向下倾斜的时候呢,我们会认为是空投行情。
那么这个时候后我们以作空为主。
当什么时候,当这个协力处于期间内的时候后呢,它可能会以震断为主。
所以这个时候呢,我们可能会进行观望。
这个时候呢,可能大家会有一个疑惑。我怎么知道这个是不是震断,
或者是不是向上倾斜,或者是不是向下倾斜?
其实向上和向下的话,这个我们比较容易判断,
因为它是协力,因为一般一段行情的话,它这个协力都会比较陡。
这个容易判断。
当然如果是说出现了这个震断的时候呢,
可能我们这一块的话会有一些上一些判断上的一些难度。
因为震断呢,它会在一定的期间内震断,
那么这个期间的多少呢,其实是不同品种它是不一样的。
这个可能根据你自己的盘感和你自己的经验来做判断。
所以有时候呢,我们在操作的时候呢,我们不清楚,
因为行情之后走出来之后呢,你才知道它是震断。
所以有时候不清楚的情况下呢,可能会在遇到一两次的滋损,
或者保本的时候呢,你就会发现它是属于震断。
那么这个时候呢,我们才能够确定它应该是震断,
所以这个时候我们才能选择观望。
那么第三个偏一度,那么这个是一个辅助吧?
那么这个可有,其实可有可无。
那么增加这个偏一度的一个目的呢,
只是为了增加我们这个交易系统的一个开仓信号。
那么这个开仓信号呢,它跟我们上面那两个的不一样,
因为上面两个呢,是用金线做我们这个交易的依据,
但这个偏一度呢,是用这个期货价,
跟这个250日金线价格之间的一个差距来判断,
是否进行开仓,或者是平仓。
通常这个通常是根据你自己的观察来,
通常是说某一段时间内,
它两期货价格跟250日金线的价格,
超出了这段时间内的一个最大价差,
这个时候呢,我们可以考虑去逆方向的去去做,
但是呢这个,这里的话就必须要再强调一下,
因为我们这个属于逆势去做,
那么只能是说,你必须要做好这个止损,
而且的话,因为是逆势,
所以我们拿到的时候,特别心里没地,
所以这只能是说那种快速上涨,快速下跌的这种情况,
突破到最大价差的情况,
我们才去操作,一般情况下,是不建议去操作的,
所以为什么说,这个这个指标呢,
只是用于补充这个信号,
但不一定说一定要去做,
核心的内容就是这个均线跟斜率,
那么这个交易系,
五分钟交易系统的一个主要特征呢,
其实就是如我第一节所说的,
我们的这个交易系统呢,
是依据这个技术分析来做的一个系统,
它的交易周期呢是五分钟,
那么它的风格呢,就是我们的短线波段交易,
它跟日内交易不同,
因为它可能会持长时间比较长,
可能是日内,也可能是几天,
也可能是半个月,甚至到一个月的时间,
那么这个跟行情有关系,
如果行情比较小,那可能这个这个操作,
那么可能日内当天日内就能够结束,
那么如果是说行情比较大的情况下呢,
按照我们这个系统呢,
可能我们可以拿到一个比较大的一个行情,
那么关于它私用的品种呢,
基本上我所发现跟观察发现的,
多数的品种基本上都能私用,
可能有一些品种在某些时间段里面,
不一定说完全能套得上,
但基本上按照这个系统去操作,
也问题不大,
而有时候呢,就是像有是板块这一块,
可能有时候更加适用于3分钟,
3分钟级别的,3分钟级别的一个交易,
那么这个这个这个用5分钟,
其实也还是问题不大的,
那么通过刚才说的,
我们的一个交易系统的核心呢,
就是均线加上这个斜率,
那么过程我们这个交易系统的核心,
那么从这张玻璃5分钟的一个K线图上,
我们大概能够比较直观的看到我们这个250日均线,
对于我们交易上的意义,
简单的上,简单上我们看了,
基本上就是说,
你这个K线上传这个250日均线的时候做多,
那么下传这个250日均线的时候做空,
当然是不是这么简单,
那肯定不是,
如果这么简单的话,
我们跟你分散这个交易系统,
就没有太大的意义,
那么我们这个交易系统呢,
主要的一个目的呢,
就是让你能够有效的判断,
什么时候是一个偷破的信号,
或者什么时候是一个有效的一个开仓的信号,
因为我们每一个行情里面,
真正解释的信号特别多,
我们所要把握住呢,
就是怎么去识别这个有效的信号,
提高我们作单的一个准确率,
提高我们作单的一个胜率,
所以呢,我们的系统更加的是,
要倾向于去识别准确的有效的开仓信号,
所以呢,我们在后面的环节里面的话,
会跟大家详细的探讨,
呃,那么这个系统的一个优缺点的话,
这里可能要跟大家做一个沟通,
因为这样可能有助于大家对这个系统,
能够进一步的了解,
那么系统的话,我个人总结的话,
它有四个优点,那么缺点,
可能我这面列的比较少,
但目前也是只是这两个缺点,
那么优点的话,它有较高的胜率,
刚才我们所说的,
我们的系统是基于,
我们的这个系统呢,就是为了,
增加这个开仓的胜率,
那么它的系统的胜率的话,
在这一年左右的次事里面,
基本上可以达到80%,
当然这个,如果你严格执行这个系统的话,
那你可能的胜率可以得到80以上,
甚至更高的一个概率,
那么较低的止损成本,
就是怎么产生的,
因为我们这个系统呢,
我们的一个好处是什么呢,
就是我们的止损呢,都有严格的一个依据,
那么通常情况下,
我们的会以回产的这一点,
或者是日均线做止损,
那么因为这个止损的空间非常的小,
那么加上我如果这个行情比较大的情况下,
在有比较大的一个波段手里的情况下呢,
我们又可以实现较大的盈亏比,
甚至可以很大,
第四的话这个频率不高,
因为我们是250日均线,
虽然是周期15分钟,
但是我们参照的均线是250日均线,
所以其实我们这个的周期,
其实是不短的,
那么它的好处呢,
就是能够给我们很充足的一个反应时间,
不会造成我们太大的一个盯盘负担,
尤其是我们很多这个乐于做期货的一个朋友来讲,
那么你去做日内高频的这种交易呢,
可能不是很现实,
那么用这种系统呢,
它既能够让你做短线,
又能够让你有一个比较大的一个波段收益,
其实这个很适合我们这些朋友做,
那么它有它的不足,
因为刚才所说的,
它的频率信号出现的频率不高,
所以呢这个系统呢,
它要求我们可能要有比较好的耐心,
对于我们这个耐心的要求会比较高,
第二呢就是这个时尚周期比较长,
刚才说到如果一段航行走出来了,
像我们最近这个玻璃对吧,
那么在这个四月份之后一直返台,
一直走走走,
走到这个1000从最低的1100多,
一直走到1800多对吧,
那么这段航期里面,
其实按照我们这个系统,
我们可以拿到将近五六百点的这种航情,
那是这个航情,
五六百点的你可能就需要拿,
拿一个来于一两个月的时间,
那么这个周期就很长,
那有时候呢,
可能我们就没有这个耐心去拿,
那么可能就会收益上,
就会打个指控,
所以说这个时尚周期场,
有时候会出现,
我们如果没有耐心的话,
很多这个系统没有耐心的情况下,
那可能我们就这个收益上,
就不能拿到最好,
就不能打到最好,
那么这个是我们本节课的一个内容,
下一节课的话,
就跟大家交流,
怎么去识别我们这个开张信号,
刚刚已经说了,
我们这个信号呢,
真真假假,
特别多,
那么我们交易做得好不好呢,
的一个关键呢,
在于我们判断这个真假信号的能力,
那么这个真假信号能力,
其实呢,
它靠我们实践,
经验很重要,
所以其实很多新手呢,
因为毕竟它交易的时间,
不是特别多,
而且专业的时间也不会特别的充足,
所以在这一块真假信号里面呢,
可能也缺乏一套有效的一个方法,
那么在下一节课的话,
我们会简单跟大家分享几个方法。